[Musique]
le plus beau de tous les cadeaux que je
pouvais faire à ce monde c'est toi ma
fille
vous devez être fiers de votre fille
évidemment que je suis fier de ma fille
elle a de qui tenir après tout regardez
moi mais gervais chef qu'est ce qui va
tâcher lionheart va devoir se mobiliser
jusqu'à ce que je sois remis sur pied
j'ai choisi qu'ils allaient me remplacer
chef guido biago bonjour à tous
[Musique]
c'est les ont rien à voir avec le fait
que tu sois une femme donc ni la queue
pour superficie réparer vous à ce que
tout un tas de choses changent dans
cette entreprise
nous avons conscience du fait que notre
situation est précaire mais à quel point
précaire lionheart est gravement endetté
endettés ils 950 millions de naira pour
être précis roi et l'heure est venue de
rembourser ces prêts d'autres 30 show
sinon vous mettrez la clé sous la porte
si nous devons partir en guerre à tana
on doit le faire ensemble sinon c'est
perdu d'avancé
ces gens comptent sur moi et je les
laisse tomber
arrêter tu es une vraie femme d'affaires
tu as toujours obtenu tout ce que tu
voulais en travaillant
détends toi je sais ce que je fais ton
père sait de quoi je suis capable c'est
pour ça qu'il m'a appelé
[Musique]